(audience applauding)
(mellow music)
- No, no, no, no.
It was when you were
on Friday Night Lights
and I was on Life.
How are you?
- No, this is my favorite
part of the panel.
This is why we love the panel.
It's like people come together
and I just get so excited.
- You get so excited.
- Yeah!
- It's good to see you!
- It's good to see you too.
I'm starting with the,
you've met Connie, obviously.
- Yes. The way we met each other,
we were at a restaurant in New York,
and we were both on NBC at the time.
I was on a show called Life.
I think you were on Friday Night Lights.
- Yes!
- And there was like a dinner,
like an upfront dinner.
- Yes, yes!
- And you and I sat next to
each other the entire night.
- Oh my God, I remember that dinner.
- And yeah. And I just, I don't know
I'm just so tickled to see you again
because I've just always thought about you
since your were so great.
- It's so nice to see you too.
I mean this is when you get so old
that you just can't even remember.
But I'm so proud of you
because this movie is gonna be so amazing.
- Aw. Well thank you!
- It's huge.
- Thank you, thank you, thank you.
- It's one thing after the
next. You're doing all right.
We're gonna get to that,
but first, Dolly Parton.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So I love her and I know you do too.
- Yes!
- So what is the connection
with Dolly and your son?
- Okay, so I did this,
there was like a anthology
series called Heartstrings.
- Yes. I know. Yes.
- And I did one of the episodes
and for the, like the premiere of it,
Dolly flew like all the cast
and crew out to Dollywood
and she, you know she's so generous
and she's so the salt of the earth, right?
So she would go around
to every single person
and she would talk to them
and just really look at
them right in the eye.
I took my mom and my son.
She sees my son and she
kind of does a double take
and she's like, "Oh!"
and she kind of caresses his cheek
and she's like, "You have
a face for the movies."
And so after that point, Wolf, my son,
goes around telling everybody
that Dolly Parton is his godmother.
(Kelly and Connie laughing)
- I mean, apparently that's all it takes.
- I love the connection.
Like he moved from point A to B.
- Exactly.
- She said I have a face for
movies, she is my godmother.
- Also, by the way,
he knows that he wants Dolly
Parton to be his godmother.
- Don't we all?
- Who wouldn't?
- Of course.
- Oh my gosh.
That's so cool.
She is so sweet.
Speaking of Henry Winkler,
like they're, they're both
just such sweet people.
So wait, your oldest son is 13 right?
- He's an alien.
I don't recognize him.
Like those 13 year old boys.
- No, that's just right
around the corner for me.
- [Kelly Clarkson] It's crazy.
- And I have to tell you this,
this happened yesterday,
which I didn't, this is, ugh.
So he comes to me two days ago
and he's like, "Mom!"
and his whole thing, it's like, you know
for Christmas, like, you
know, what do you want more?
He's like, "A girlfriend."
I'm like, Okay, I can't
buy you a girlfriend.
Like that's illegal.
And then, and then, so
two days ago he's like,
"So my friends and I were
walking down the hallway
and we were just asking
if anybody wanted to be,
wanted to be my girlfriend.
And someone said, "Yes."
And he was like, "Can I have her?"
- [Connie] Oh my god!
- [Kelly Clarkson] "Can I have her?"
- Let's have a conversation.
- Start teaching them now,
start teaching 'em now.
- See, you want him to come to you.
You want him to come to you.
- Hold on a second.
I was like, "What is her name?"
And he's like, "I don't know."
- I said, "Okay."
I was like, "I, I don't
think this is how it works."
I was like, I think I was
like, "How about this?"
You know, cause my mom
was pretty strict on me
with like dating and everything.
Like, there were rules right.
And so he wants to know
when can we start this?
I'm like "Okay, when you're
ready, let's talk about it."
So I was like,
"Why don't you spend like a
month, like get to know her.
Tell me some information about
her, like what she likes."
Like that kind of thing.
I was like, "Consider
yourself special enough
that you want someone else
that's just as special."
So then last night, this was two days ago.
- This is good. I'm gonna remember this.
- Listen, two days ago was that talk.
Last night, he comes to me, he's like,
"I got her mom, she's my girlfriend."
I'm like, "Hold on a second.
This is not what we said."
And I'm like, "What is her name?"
He's like, "Her name is Kalin."
And I said, "Okay, what is she into?"
And he goes, "I don't know,
but she takes English like me!"
I'm like, "Every kid at
your school takes English.
This is not acceptable."
- This is not special.
- It's literally, it's
like just the title.
Like, just to say like,
"I have a girlfriend, I have a girl."
You know that kind of stuff.
- But isn't that funny
'cause it makes you realize you have to,
we actually have to teach them everything.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my gosh.
- Like you think that, you realize that
they don't know what that even means
to have a girlfriend.
You know what I mean?
- No, and I asked, I was like,
"Did you guys hold hands?
Like, how did this happen?"
And he was like, "I held both of them."
And I said, "What do you mean?"
And he literally went, he was like, here.
He was like this.
He was like, "So, do you take English?"
Like it was, like, I was like, this is-
- How incredibly awkward.
- I know.
Awkward and innocent,
but look compared to what
some other 13 year olds
could be doing these days.
It's like-
I'll take that.
So, yeah.
- Oh my gosh. I am not
looking forward to that.
So I want to talk about your project.
This is amazing.
So this is called Black Adam.
So tell us about it and who you play.
- Well, Black Adam is a superhero movie.
It's big DC superhero movie.
And as you know, Dwayne is the lead.
He's Black Adam
and I play character named
Adriana, who in the movie,
the movie takes place in
this fictitious country
called Condock.
And I'm sort of the
leader of this movement
that is fighting the oppressors.
So there's a oppressive
gang called Inner Gang
and they're trying to take control.
And my character is like the,
it's like a Indiana Jonesy,
Laura Crofty...
- Love!
- Thing that's sort of, that's, you know,
trying to fight against them
and keep her country
peaceful and stuff like that.
- What a cool role!
- Oh, it's so cool.
It's so cool.
- [Connie] You're like a badass lady.
It's really, really cool.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I love it.
- Of all the projects I've done, you know,
I've done a lot of things my
children cannot watch, Right?
- Yeah. Sex life.
- Yeah. And the L word,
like yeah, the list goes on.
But no, this one for me,
like it's super special
because my kids can watch it, you know?
And it's like, it does give me like
some bragging rights, which I like.
- This is when you're cool.
- This is when I'm cool.
- It's so amazing when that happens.
It's like, I've done all these things
but this is why you, Okay cool.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I love that.
Well, let's, let's look at a clip.
Here's Sarah Shahi in
Black Adam, everybody.
- We don't have time for this.
Teth Adam first, then the crown.
- You don't have any authority here.
Teth Adam has done nothing.
- Teth Adam is not who you think he is.
- And how would you know?
- We have access to ancient text
that have been kept secret for centuries.
- And what exactly do these
supposed ancient texts say?
- They say that his rage
nearly destroyed Condock.
We flew all the way over here
to stop it from happening again.
(audience applause)
- All right everybody!
You can see Black Adam only in theaters
Starting October 21st.